one of my mantras in life is teach
everything you know because that turns
into or we have this idea that only
experts can teach and the the main
principle behind my book Authority is
that people don't teach because they're
experts we perceive them as experts
because they teach right it's chicken
and egg and we have it backwards and so
in that if you step into a world where
you're like okay I'm just going to teach
what I learned today then you build that
habit you write it down and someone's
like okay I'm following this web
designer who is brand new but they're on
a journey to get a a job at you know web
agency and they're just every day
they're sharing and teaching what they
learned and they're doing it from a
beginner's mindset and of you can learn
way more from that person if you're
following like two steps behind them
then following the super Advanced expert
who forgot how like who cannot relate in
any way to the problems that an absolute
beginner is
facing